this is one of the children's wards in
the Schiffer hospital the Central
Hospital in Gaza City this boy here is 8
years old he suffered injuries in his a
toon area of Gaza yesterday and this
girl here is 4 years old a mother her
father and her sister were all killed
she's being looked after here by ants
the little girl hasn't been conscious
since the death of her family she
doesn't know what has happened and
doctors are saying they're doing
everything they can to try and help her
now what's interesting is when we've
been speaking to the family here very
often when you speak to people in Gaza
who have suffered these extraordinary
losses or injuries there's actually a
resilience and a determination that
resisting and backing the actions of the
powers like Hamas and other militant
groups that that carry out the what they
would describe as resistance is the
right thing that speaking to the arm
tear really interesting she's just I was
holding the hand of the girl and saying
we should stop firing the rockets into
Israel and Israel has to stop this when
children like this a four-year-old girl
are being left in this condition yet to
wake up and yet to find out that her
whole family immediate family is dead
surely it's time to stop and wake up and
end this and that's an interesting point
to make because clearly on the political
level there is still an absence of an
obvious deal broker president Sisi has
overseen a deterioration in relations
between Hamas and Egypt so really what
is interesting about speaking to the
people here is that they want logic and
just human emotion to factor into the
decisions to de-escalate this crisis and
not just allow it all to happen on a
political level where seems like this
are ignored